welcome to this video you why scoochie
who's that pretty set a new handle sorry
I have to check it again and it seems
fairly fresh that handle okay so let's
get going I am interesting that's a rare
line v6 it's probably not super great
but still quite an interesting choice
black wants to play j5 next f3 is a move
I would leave but let's just develop
stuff and play lateral moves and
probably we get something know that that
gives the whole game and independent
character I was thinking you might play
you 6 and we have some kind of Queens
Indian right you fire him that's a bit
weakening but may be possible okay
Bishop to b4 something that could prove
to be quite an annoyance so play let's
go away three it's a bit slow ish but
still yeah I wonder if I should go H&I
now I have to go edge for me and not
have to bits but almost yeah let's go H
for now g5 is an interesting move but it
doesn't have any square from there so
probably I have to go back
yeah the question is for or not probably
probably yes sir because I'd like to
have that diagonal blocked the drawback
is exactly that move it done simply
directly at XD for him hmm yeah i was
thinking e5 dad interesting position
maybe I have to give give up the g2 pawn
in some situations so okay taking them
it's hard not to take it my night on d 2
is really not a great piece ok let's
take pawn takes I wonder if Bishop d3 as
a move I'm min ki can take you can take
g2 that's the main objection there
okay let's let's play let's play it in a
shop way 494 mmmm if he takes on g2 for
example yes I expected that now I wanted
to go Bishop d3 I hope that it's not or
maybe maybe to eat to actually to not be
in that wreck Queenie 7 check I mean
after which you have to go king of one
yeah maybe maybe I want to Castle and
then just play on this weekend King
position I mean yes move tons of porn so
it's it's not so easy for him to find a
safe place for the king this should be
too i will just castle and let him take
the exchange if you really insist okay
if I a yak a high castle now he has at
five that's interesting at five
okay let's start with that move now I
wanted to go Bishop f4 now whoa that's
really really really tough position this
is why I didn't want to castle in the
first place to have that move okay now
Bishop c4 was my idea take stakes and
then take on d6 or go to the 64 Queen
txt 594 you will take her very
interesting I don't really know if this
is any good sorry for that flinging here
to switch off my mobile the problem is
actually that he has checks on the
e-file with the Queen home jack yeah
exactly this check eggs eggs and and
Queenie foyer is that the point yeah
he's seen services it's that strong
probably i saw i put a bit late if i
take these six and then queen d5 check
however it's firmly not going to work
Quincy one he's got what Roxy Asia and
great stuff yeah totally weird yeah
that's one of those cases where you know
you had a good position but somehow
probably screw it up time morning that
was certainly a good position for me
with this ridiculous King position but
yeah I miss plated
and this season I am so you can be
reasonably reasonably sure that it isn't
that solid sheet you played a bit
computer ish I have to say but it's not
cheating anyway that looks bad okay why
okay so let's check there and it was a
very interesting position really and I
really don't believe that this is any
good damn black but ok so if five went
here now I went to d5 he takes I played
here castles Teague's f5f for ya the
engine is I have it on equal about equal
so it I didn't have anything great there
that we like wins or something like that
computer gives this funky move Knight f3
it's definitely a position that is very
difficult for black to handle because
offers as I said really ridiculous King
position if I cancel something like that
is given by the engine check takes 9 c 4
into equal whatever that means still a
super-sharp position hmm here and this
is not not working you're due to exactly
this tactic if not for that it would be
nice for white but that is definitely a
problem and I cannot go here because
this happens yeah yeah I'm just lost
their I have no have nothing this is a
bit better why didn't I do that actually
can't be an interesting at least
you can play here now but he's clearly
better now I was a very strong resource
yeah what you play this I mean that's
not exactly my kind of chess weakening
yourself and stuff like that but seems
that it was okay there was no never
announcement no great thing my hunch
elder said during the actual live
commentary was that white should have
something because as I said of his very
yeah this is this is like super Lucia
but if I don't get there it doesn't
really matter that much it seems yeah
that's a cool move by the engine now
this is check clearly bad and this isn't
also interesting the comp gives this as
the best move and then 95 that's that
that's quite attractive you have I get
the night over to g5 why I tactical
means it gives equal however with this
line check which is still kind of tricky
not really equal equal okay that was
interesting thanks for watching